hi i'm sweet anita and a lot of people
have been asking a lot of details about
my stalker this has been going on since
october
last year or so i've been assaulted i've
been chased and people have
had to restrain my stalker out in public
as he wouldn't leave me alone and
throughout all of this i had planned to
make a video just covering my situation
but in doing all of the research i
possibly could in trying to find
solutions
and an end to this absolute nightmare i
found that so many other people are
going through the same
it's a terrifying situation to be in
especially when you don't feel that
there's anyone there to help you
my stalker started following me around
and
sleeping in my back garden he started
staring through my letterbox
like i would come down the stairs in the
morning get on with my day and then just
be like wait a minute and look back at
the door
and like this letterbox would slowly
close as his eyes disappeared behind the
door
and so he started knocking on my door as
well a lot for hours on end
just not giving up just constantly i
almost worried that his knuckles would
bleed it was so relentless
he'd sleep behind my house and watch it
waiting for me to come out
and he'd follow me to shops um he'd
constantly persistently
message me and go and say awful things
in my chat he threatened to kill me
and the police response has been
incredibly underwhelming
after he assaulted me i had a witness i
had a lot of evidence
and the police did nothing yep
you need a lot for the police to do
something about that
online it's not proved
it's not you know you have to find out
who it is it's not it's like whenever
you get robbed police are not going to
try and who robbed you
they're not going to try to file find
out who robbed you first whenever you
get robbed
they show up three hours after you call
them you know because it's not a
priority they have a priority list
they're not meant to catch you and they
act upon something that happened
just like a sort of a doctor you know a
doctor can't operate if you don't have
any symptoms
and something happening to you is a
symptom let's say you get attacked by
someone
you have to be able to identify who he
is
you know what i mean a hundred percent
or else you know
well there's not much we can do about
that you know it's probably just uh
and then after that they're gonna shame
you depending on what you're oh yeah but
you know
you you put this and that online and you
put yourself out there what do you
expect i always have that
rhetoric so yeah they eventually felt
pressured to do something after everyone
was kind enough to start adding
the police on twitter and kind of
getting upset with the uk police for not
acting there was definitely a lot more
done during that time
but it still eventually amounted to
nothing changing for me
and a restraining order was so slow to
put in place
that it didn't prevent him from
harassing me over time and it didn't
actually do anything because he
continues to harass me
and breach it and nothing's being done
about that either
i think what's scary is that he can
assault me and get away with it
but also that when they finally went out
to pick him up off the street to
question him about that incident
he was actually on his way to my house
with a knife when they found him
and despite that being incredibly
damning especially when they're already
picking him up
over a separate assault incident
they still released him a three-minute
walk away from my house
this man was crazy he came to visit for
two weeks and ended up moving down the
street from me
he didn't stop obsessing and he
constantly denied everything that he was
doing as
he did it he found ways to join my games
while i was gaming with my friends
and constantly beg me to go into a
private vc with him and no matter how
much i refused he'd constantly beg
and it escalated from there he started
putting my details in chat
and trying to encourage other people to
stalk me doxing my
home my street my address he started
trying to release things about me that
were incredibly private including
medical conditions and things like that
and he made awful threats and awful
comments constantly some of which i
shared on twitter
and when i reported to the police that
he was about to turn up at my house
um he threatened to kill me on stream he
said i'll be there in 15 minutes
and they didn't turn up for 30 minutes
and even they didn't actually turn up
what they did was
ring me back after 30 minutes to explain
why they weren't going to do anything to
help me
you're still alive yeah all right this
is what we're not gonna do
[Laughter]
oh my god oh i'm sorry i'm just having
flashbacks
[ __ ] and i found out quite a lot of
really terrible things during that time
they were actually blaming twitch at the
time
for not giving them details about the
accounts
used but the thing about that was is
that all they had to do was request that
information
and they weren't doing it and when i
asked them to request their information
formally and go through the correct
channels they told me directly
it was not in the public interest to
waste funding pursuing it because it
would take too much time and effort
i later found out that the time and
effort is to write a one-page subpoena
for the identity and information
um which they weren't willing to do and
was not as costly or
time costly as they were claiming it was
so i faced a lot of barriers in trying
to get a conviction
and eventually even though it took a lot
of fighting i got there in the end
and i got a restraining order but he
breaches it constantly
includes no contact and he definitely
breaches that very regularly
making death threats and also
um it seems as though i'm quite
concerned i haven't released this until
today but
um he threatened to kill my mom and my
animals and
just a couple of days after somebody
broke into my mom's house
which has obviously left her incredibly
scared and traumatized
and we're not entirely sure what to do
about that seeing as the police
seem to be completely inactive and
uninterested in the case
i am not the only one who's facing this
disinterest
and this lack of investment in solving
and you know prosecuting this
i know what it's like to have somebody
invade your personal space and then you
have no peace of mind afterwards
it's hard to feel comfortable in your
own home when someone has come in
and you don't know for what
you don't know why you don't know when
but they were there
you know they're gonna come back exactly
so then you start to be a little bit
more tense and what was once a home
is now unknown territory because you
can't really define it
and that's a frightening thing um
you know especially when you've got all
the stresses of the world and all the
stuff that exists to
not be able to feel safe in the one
place you should be able to feel safe
which is your own home
um yeah someone's robbing you of
something extremely important
many of the other streamers you're about
to see all this i interviewed loads of
other streamers about this
and they are saying exactly the same
thing they all live in different places
around the world and they're facing
exactly the same in action
um from the police it seems to be a
universal problem
and i think that you know being an
entertainer is always going to be
dangerous and life-threatening
until the platforms we use and the
police start
finding systems and means to protect us
and take it seriously stalking at best
can be psychologically damaging
but at worst it can be fatal and bianca
devins was just 17 years old
when she paid the price for being an
entertainer and being on the internet
in our current state we don't have
enough things in place to protect people
online
and bianca devins made contact with one
of her viewers
on discord and arranged to meet up with
him in a jealous rage when she started
spending time with another one of her
viewers
he killed her in his car and posted
pictures of it
all over the internet and within hours
someone was already selling
t-shirts with those pictures on her
family have been trying to remove
the pictures from the internet since her
death
over a year ago and it's proven
impossible
and now not only have they lost her but
bianca is never going to have her
dignity and privacy
um even in death because those pictures
are up
you know it's tragic it's an absolutely
tragic loss of life
and it could be avoided if we had more
safety things in place if we had more
things in place to protect
those who provide content online gwyneth
paltrow was pursued for 17 years by an
absolutely insane stalker
she was fearing for her life and fearing
for her children's lives
and she went to court with an abundance
of evidence of persistent harassment
and still didn't secure a conviction
and it's terrifying to think of cases
like mayu
tomita who is in japan and she was
she reported her stalker a month before
he stabbed her
60 times viewers are able to find us
very easily and it's terrifying that
there's nothing we can do
and that even when we warn the police
that something bad might happen to us
they still do nothing until it's too
late
one of the things that i find really
challenging about all of this and
speaking up about it too
is that so many people want to blame me
they say if you learn martial arts if
you move house if you get a dog if you
get a gun
then everything will be okay and you
will be safer
if you learned martial arts dnd she's
still a five foot two woman
what is y'all talking about and
irrespective of what she is if someone's
trying to attack you and you don't know
when they're going to attack
if they have a weapon and they have the
element of surprise you're still toast
like what kind of rhetoric is this yay
uh if someone's out there trying to get
you uh
every man for himself do what you got to
do get a gun what's the point of living
in society then
she gets a gun she kills him then she's
charged for murder
well i mean she doesn't live in america
so yeah
guns aren't exactly easily accessible
where she is in uk exactly
you know get a knife because you know
they'd love knife crime get some acid
throw acid on him before he throws acid
on you that's a dummy [ __ ] i heard today
and i've heard some pretty
today but i don't think it's the answer
in countries where
so many more people have a gun there are
still stalkers and there are even people
who get
shot by their stalkers and countries
where people get dogs in countries where
people
move house all of these things are not
necessarily measures that
eradicate stalking or stop it or prevent
it
who has limited money to move house
every time this is perfect victim
blaming
perfect victim blaming move like what i
love my home now i feel unsafe because
someone else
i can't call the police i have to move
how is that a really this reasonable
solution it's expensive you know what i
mean
moving is a lengthy process and then
what happens when you move in they find
you again what's the solution then
move again how many times i have to move
do i have to leave the country
you'll have to leave the continent
that's like today
sheryl hooper is proof that moving house
doesn't save you
and i can safely say it takes months to
move house and it takes seconds to dock
someone
destiny himself said that he moved and
before he even got into his new place
he had already been doxxed again and so
unfortunately moving doesn't solve the
problem but in cheryl hooper's case
she was found again after moving home to
escape her stalker
and he found her and managed to murder
her it's
it's proven time and time again that the
fact that women have access to these
things has not prevented
many women from being stalked and i feel
it's unfortunate and that it kind of
distracts from the real problem
which is that there are things that
could actionably be put in place
online and by the police to help prevent
and prosecute that are simply not
available right now
the british crime survey found that an
estimated
five million people in my country get
stalked
every year that's insane you don't have
to be a slippery
you don't have to be an ego you can be a
dude you could be anybody
you could be any age now this is
something that is so universal
it applies to every police force it
applies to every country
there seems to be very few places on
this planet
where you will get adequate support
and help if you're being stoked that's
insane you don't have to be in the
public eye to be in danger this is
something we need to change not just for
content creators but for
all of us because we might end up
knowing someone who loses their life
because of this
and it doesn't have to be this way and
you can get involved and you can help
us to make this a safer place to create
content
and encourage the police to take this
seriously
i want to blow this up i want to blow it
out the water i want to show people that
this is real and it is worth prosecuting
i wouldn't hold my breath
i sympathize and it is serious
and i highly doubt the police are going
to tasters
it's such a hard crime to prove in some
situations yeah not all i know
in your specifically probably not but i
mean a lot very hard
um also the time that they would end up
doing for it
so minimal that in terms of the research
that they put into it
versus what kind of conviction or
whatever's going to come out of it
it's minimal you know and since police
departments are so like results oriented
things like that aren't going to be
rewarded and so they always think like
what's the priority all right well what
things that people are doing in their
private time the things that they're
smoking right murders
you know and for the murders well it
actually has to happen
and that's the unfortunate part of the
way the system works it's like
especially with the you know invention
of the internet and everyone having so
much access to information it's very
hard to imagine
that these things are going to change i
hope they do i hope we find systems and
i think we find ways
to punish people to deter them from
engaging such behaviors and show them
there is consequences
because it there's nothing acceptable
about living in society where every day
you feel unsafe because someone is going
out of their way to make you feel unsafe
that's a problem it's a real real
problem
but i'm also a pragmatic person and i
look at like
all right you know what can the police
do for me and there's just things that i
know that i'm going to deal with in my
personal life
that they will never be there to help
nope and i think it's great that you're
trying to change it and i hope it works
out i think i just for
whatever reason i just don't believe it
and it's crazy how they're gonna put
less money
just globally they put less money into
mental health
issues and how to solve that and they
put more money into the police system
they put money in equipment but not
necessarily
to make processes faster you know what i
mean you're going to have more equipment
to enforce whatever you want to enforce
but you're going to have to have proof
and then
it's not for our benefit when they look
at their priority list like
stalking is not gonna be the top let's
say someone is talking right let's say
someone is following you around and all
this stuff
okay you tell the police they're like
cool we know what are they gonna do
are they gonna wait outside your home
for three days to see the stalker come
in
and then what are they gonna charge them
with a misdemeanor maybe one to two
years
so for them there's like in terms of
what they're putting in versus what
they're getting out
it's not worth it this is not an
endorsement this is not saying it's okay
i'm just saying like those systems i
understand how they function
yeah and they're not going to prioritize
something like stalking
and that's why it's one of those things
where by the time they take notice it's
already too late
because the man has to have done so the
person individual has to have done
something
for you to get a sense of peace
well you're already gone
and you died in fear it's crazy yeah
it's not effective yeah and when you try
to get something done the process takes
so much time yep
so long yup all these procedures and
everything takes so long to apply
and to get done and to actually and it's
paperwork and they don't want to do
paperwork ain't nobody want to file
papers
that's pretty much what it is so you
know listen i think i think initiative
is great i hope it works out
and um yeah hopefully the situation
eventually goes by and
she finds a way out of it you know
because uh nobody should have to deal
with that
everyone should be able to have a place
that they call home without someone else
coming inside and trying to invade it
so that's how i feel tell us what you
guys think in the comments below
[Music]